a central idea in biology is that
structure determines function and
function also influences structure the
shapes and Arrangements of a structure
determine what it does and the task
affects the structure needed it is a key
idea in engineering
look at an everyday object like a tool a
hammer is a handheld tool with a head
and a handle the long handle allows it
to be easily grasped there are two
opposite ends to the metal head one flat
and one claw each end has a unique shape
to fit a specific function but not both
this is their structure but what is
their function the flat face pounds
nails while the claw removes Nails
Hammer structure is built with a
specific purpose in mind and this
determines its function in this case two
functions this is the structure function
connection now let's think about living
systems which are organized as a
hierarchy consider a school with
classrooms within each classroom are
desks and each desk is made of legs and
a tabletop every larger thing is made up
of smaller things and each level has
specialized structure and function this
hierarchy is also found in biology from
an ecosystem to a molecule life contains
basic units of structure and function
which is essential to understand how a
system works
let's start big on the scale of living
things and look at an ecosystem
let's look at the structure of the
tropical rainforest ecosystem found near
the equator there are trees flowering
plants Birds butterflies and other
species in this diverse ecosystem look
closer and observe specific populations
of species interacting with each other
like this butterfly population
pollinating specific flowering plants a
mutually helpful relationship
each species is dependent on others for
its survival and or reproduction
the more complex the ecosystem structure
the more species interactions and the
better the ecosystem functions species
interactions are part of the rainforest
structure and they help the ecosystem
function in important processes such as
pollination and survival structure
determines function in an ecosystem like
the rainforest
let's zoom in and look at the structure
function relationship within an
individual her body is composed of 11
major organ systems including
cardiovascular musculoskeletal and
respiratory systems each body system has
a structure of organs that work together
to carry out functions as she climbs
elevated terrain her cardiovascular
system works to increase her heart rate
the cardiovascular system is made of the
heart blood and lymphatic vessels that
interact to transport essential
substances Like Oxygen to and from all
organs and tissues of her body
structure determines function in a body
system
[Music]
looking a little closer within her heart
we see millions of individual cells
working together to pump blood
throughout her body looking even closer
we see each heart cell is a tiny factory
made of organelles like mitochondria
that have specific jobs to support the
cell's function each mitochondrion
consists of a highly folded inner
membrane with increased surface area to
facilitate chemical reactions that
convert food to ATP to power up each
cell
structure determines function in a cell
the structure and function connection is
found at all levels of biological
organization
including the molecular one
within the blood flowing through her
blood vessels our erythrocytes or red
blood cells inside each red blood cell
is an important protein called
hemoglobin each protein has a unique
shape that allows it to function
hemoglobin protein is globular shaped
and made of four protein chains with
each one folded onto itself
in the center of each polypeptide is a
positively charged iron containing
compound
for each iron containing compound a
negatively charged oxygen binds to the
positively charged iron
and this allows for the transport of
oxygen in the blood throughout the body
structure determines function in
molecules like hemoglobin
structure determines function and
function also influences structures
if the structure of an ecosystem body
system or molecule changes the function
changes
this principle makes sure that
biological systems function properly
since each cell and molecule is as
precisely structured as a hammer
[Music]